okay welcome everyone for the afternoon
session of the last day of the quantum
protocols workshop
so our just a reminder that you're
welcome to ask questions any time by
using the Q & A or the chat or asking to
the charts that I or one of the
panelists allow you to speak up so Robin
said please interrupt him with questions
so please interrupt him with questions
so for the first talk we're happy to
have Robin bloom cohort from Sandia and
he's going to tell us that not all
benchmarks are created equal thank you
very much tomorrow so this is this is a
grand new adventure for all of us and
especially for me I've never actually
given a full zoom talk before if you
haven't I can tell you that it's deeply
intimidating to be staring into that
tiny green light on the top of your
computer screen and knowing that there
are 20 or 30 people staring back and
having no idea who they are or what they
think so I'm just going to assume that
you are all following along enjoying
yourselves tremendously laughing at my
jokes and probably not wearing any pants
and that's gonna make me feel better
about my talk so this is essentially
100% an overview talk they're the what I
was sort of asked to do was to talk
about the role that benchmarks play and
how sort of applied quantum computing
people theorists and experimentalists
use benchmarks to study how as built
quantum computing systems perform and
what I anticipated was that the audience
was going to be overwhelmingly computer
scientists doing terrifyingly technical
probabilistically checkable proofs
things so this was intended as a pretty
broad overview talk I'm going to take
license to plug a little bit of my
groups work at the end
and I will also take the license to
express opinions about things but really
I'd like to go through this fairly
quickly and leave significant time for
questions at the end and or in the
middle and just spawn a discussion this
is an area where as you'll see in the
talk I think what we desperately need is
more discussion more creativity and more
communication because there are a lot of
really interesting questions that
basically come down to what is this
particular benchmark measuring what is
it telling us about the system I don't
believe that there is one benchmark to
rule them all and in the darkness bind
them
I think we need a lot and we need to
understand what they're good for
so please do interrupt at any point to
ask questions argue with me or just tell
me that I need a haircut
um this is the abstract for this talk
and if you want to skim this while I'm
talking go ahead I basically want to
emphasize the last sentence here the
overarching message of my talk is all of
these benchmarks are distinct tools in a
diverse toolbox almost every known
protocol and benchmark really measures
some distinct and particular thing and
we need more of them and we need to
understand what they're measuring and
how those properties that they do
measure or probe contribute to the
useful tasks for quantum computers so I
can't tell whether Steve Flemmi ax is
actually on the call right now but I'm
gonna I'm gonna fantasize that he is
Steve has been giving me crap for years
about not putting citations in my talks
so Steve I have good news and I have bad
news the good news is I made a
bibliography and I tried to collect
every I am still trying to collect every
single paper that anyone could ever
point at me and say you should have
cited this not every paper that I would
cite but every relevant paper about the
assessment of the performance of digital
quantum compute
components which is my best shortest
phrase for describing what I do and what
I'm interested in and so far this
bibliography has about 1,500 sources in
it you can see the breakdown on the
slide here so so Steve the good news is
I'm going to talk about all of these
sources the bad news is I'm not going to
explicitly list any of them so
nananananana sorry but you should look
at it as a positive because by trying to
list 1500 sources it actually does take
over a hundred pages what I did do with
these instead of listing them here is I
classified them not using machine
learning or anything just using my
opinion about what this paper was about
and I drew you a picture of this so you
can see that there are a bunch of
different categories here the area of
each circle tells you how many papers
out of this 1500 that I found seem to
fall into this category these are not
exclusive they're intended to be
overlapping one another so the biggest
circle here corresponds to 428 papers
the smallest corresponds to 5 papers and
there are many papers that fall into two
or three or four categories but I wanted
to put this up to give those of you who
are not immersed in this particular
field the way that I am an idea of
what's relevant and what people write
papers about in this field so while
we're staring at this I also classified
the papers that were about experimental
assessment of the quantum computer
component performance by what technology
they were in so I'm not gonna try to
move my pointer around to pointed all
these things but you notice there's a
big blob for state tomography for
processed tomography for randomized
benchmarking which Joseph mentioned
extensively in his talk for a holistic
bench marking which is the sort of thing
that psycho benchmarking is and what I'm
actually going to talk about mostly
today there's a lot about verification
and certification which I believe is
something that has come up elsewhere in
this workshop
and then some smaller blobs here for
things like calibration free tomography
efficient or low rank tomography
characterization of Hamiltonians
Lindblad Ian's non Markovian noise etc
this at least gives you an idea of
what's out there and I want to use this
as a kind of a foil for talking about
what's important because if you ask
what's important and you use this
particular blob diagram you would expect
that we ought to spend the next hour
talking about state tomography and
optical continuous variable systems
since the largest pool of theory papers
are about state tomography and the
largest pool of experimental papers
apply it to optical continuous variables
of course this is a historical artifact
this bibliography goes back more than 20
years and we spent 20 years writing
about tomography of optical Vigna
functions because frankly we didn't have
anything better to do now we do now we
have actual 5 to 50 qubit quantum
computers that are popping up all over
the place so I want to talk about what's
important to do now that we actually
have these things so one of the things
that I've perceived is in the last
couple of years shockingly people have
started giving money for quantum
computing and the the numbers have they
have dollar signs in front of them and
they have decimal places after them and
there's a startling number of decimal
places the whole field especially the
experimental and the engineering field
have just blown up like this so there's
a huge amount of funding there's a huge
amount of engineering there's a huge
amount of new people there's a huge
amount of hype and it turns out that a
lot of people now want metrics and
benchmarks they're not sure what that
means but they want them apparently this
is driven by wanting to quantify how
good quantum computers are why are we
spending all this money on them trying
to determine which of two or three
different quantum computers or quantum
computer companies is better trying to
figure out how rapidly this is
progressing over time and I think
eventually it probably all comes down to
profit
these are questions they might not be
the best questions I want to stop and I
want to go back and I want to talk about
the questions that we could be asking
with metrics and benchmarks what could
we be measuring what do we actually want
to know about as built quantum computers
there are a lot of those questions and
if you don't engage with the question
then it's not possible to answer it well
one of the things that I've seen is
there have been attempts to answer the
questions without actually asking what
the question was in the first place so
we might want to know does this thing
work we might want to know does this
thing do
what the manufacturer said it does is
this thing good enough for what I want
to do with it how well does this thing
work
which of these two or three different
things is better and there's questions
like what does this thing do anyway and
how can I make it better and what's
wrong with this thing
what could I do with this thing if I
used it correctly what will happen when
I push the on button on this thing how
many of these things would I need if I
wanted to accomplish something and most
generally what can this thing do all of
these are distinct questions they have
overlapping answers but they're not the
same question and every single one of
them is something that's addressed by
benchmarking some of these are
fundamentally binary testing questions
we would like tools to answer questions
like does this thing work or not does
this thing do what the label said or not
is this thing good enough for my task or
not but some of these questions have
quantitative answers they are
benchmarking questions is this thing
good enough falls in both categories how
well does this thing work
I need a quantity
answer that which of these things is
better I pretty much need quantitative
answers for that what could I do is this
thing what will happen when I use this
thing these are questions that
quantitative benchmarking protocols that
give out sort of scalar-valued numbers
tend to answer and then the last
category I would call characterization
questions like what does this thing do
that's not a number
that's a qualitative question it can be
extremely detailed it can be numerical
but it's not usually described by a
number how can I make this thing better
I need to understand what it's doing
wrong what's wrong with this thing what
could I do with this thing what will
happen when I use this thing these are
all questions that require some detailed
descriptive predictive characterization
of the device so yes question yes please
often up more so from the computing
science community you hear the word
learning being used well how would you
equate that to one of these or would you
put in a different category I there's a
thing I don't like about the word
learning which is that it gets used in
many different ways I feel like there is
sometimes a bit of motte-and-bailey
going on where learning will get used
provisionally to mean one thing and then
if it doesn't work for that the meaning
gets redefined I think it's a very
powerful word but a friend of mine
recently told me about splitters and
Glamour's two different kinds of
scientists splitters like taking things
apart into their littlest pieces glomer
z' like combining ideas together and
seeing big pictures I am by temperament
very much a splitter as you can see from
this slide I have taken these questions
and split them apart into three
categories learning is a powerful word
but it also frustrates me because it
could mean almost anything with that
said I would say that learning either
describes characterization most of the
time or as in the the
work that followed from Scott Aaronson
's learnability of quantum states paper
its meaning something else that at this
point is interesting and hard for me to
pin down
so thanks what I've tried to do here is
to divide these tasks and the protocols
that solve these problems into three
categories tests benchmarks
characterization and my heritage is
mostly in the characterization side of
things where the goal is to measure
everything that's necessary about a
thing and how it functions that's
necessary to predict what will happen
when you use it and this is the task
that usually requires the most effort in
the most data the other extreme are
tests they certify or verify a property
there's been a lovely literature in the
last few years about quantum property
testing hypothesis testing also falls in
this as an certification usually falls
into this category in principle these
tests report yes or no and conceptually
this is the easiest thing to do and in
practical experimental resources it's
also the easiest thing to do because
you're only trying to get one bit out in
practice I find if these things are
almost never directly useful and the
reason is that it's very hard to come up
with a real-world quantum problem where
the answer really is binary um an
example would be does this gate satisfy
the fault tolerance theorem well first
of all we don't know exactly what the
fault tolerance threshold is we know
certain proven thresholds but they're
just bounds so if I tell you that the
gates error rate is above a known
threshold that doesn't mean that it is
actually above the threshold furthermore
just being barely on one side of the
threshold or the other is not especially
useful because the resources required to
build a quantum error correcting code
scale with the actual value of that
error rate in practice
tests usually serve as preliminaries to
designing benchmarks or characterization
protocols they demonstrate that it's
possible to probe some property and then
in practice you actually want to measure
it rather than testing it there are
exceptions to that but that's how I've
seen them in as the field is developed
all of these testing and benchmarking
and characterization protocols in
general and of course I'm going to get
in trouble for saying all most of them
work in the same basic way um first you
run on your qubit or processor or device
which I've sort of described here as a
black box with buttons on it meaning
that you don't have the ability to reach
in there and do quantum things to it you
can only control it via classical
controls that we push with our classical
fingers so you take that and you run on
it a test suite of quantum circuits and
for those of you who haven't seen a
quantum circuit I've drawn one here you
repeat each circuit many times you
record the statistics and then you
analyze the results and most of the
coolness is in what's the test suite and
how do you analyze the results as a
result of that analysis you estimate a
vector a matrix a scaler some sort of
numerical quantity that tells you about
the error performance of the device and
lately I've been giving a lot of talks
to non experts in quantum computing and
I have to explain over and over again
that when we benchmark quantum computers
we're not measuring flops we're not
measuring speed we're not measuring
bandwidth
we're basically never measuring anything
except error performance because errors
are so overwhelmingly important at this
point down the road we all hope there
will be some day when we actually care
how fast something runs but right now
it's dwarfed by does it run at all and
if so what's it's error rate so that's a
big difference from the classical
benchmarking literature where errors
cease to be a dominant thing back in
about 1947 also point out in contrast to
so a lot of the computers
approaches my community of sort of semi
physics II or experimental computer
scientists who work with hardware are
not crypto paranoid we don't worry about
the Mechanical Turk problem in other
words if Google comes and says look our
computer did this we don't ask them we
don't poke around and try to figure out
where they have a very small person
hiding in the dill fridge there's
exceptions to that and actually Google's
quantum supremacy experiment is one of
the you know really clear exceptions
where they did try to demonstrate that
this was something that even if they had
hidden a classical supercomputer in
their dill fridge it wouldn't have
helped but usually from a benchmarking
perspective we're much more concerned
with does the thing appear to be
operating according to spec we do worry
about systematic errors ie are we
actually measuring what we think we are
but not about adversarial errors with
some exceptions this is maybe a good
time to take a deep breath ask if
there's any questions ok I'm gonna go on
as
that there's still a world out there and
I'm not just talking to my laptop
I've been intentionally vague so far I
keep saying does this thing work or what
does this thing do so what things are we
talking about obviously sometimes we're
talking about quantum computers we have
little ones today we're getting ready
for a future where hopefully we're going
to have bigger more capable ones today
the range of quantum computers is
probably about 5 to 50 cubits in the
future hopefully the sky is the limit
but we're not just talking about testing
benchmarking and characterizing quantum
computers or quantum processors we're
also talking very much about testing and
benchmarking and characterizing their
components individual qubits subsets of
qubits or possibly queued its individual
logic operations gates state
preparations measurements on subroutines
like the cycles that Joe talked about in
the previous talk or entire gate sets
that work together on a subset of qubits
or subroutines like the QFT
or like a parity measurement that appear
in larger algorithms and in a different
sense entire algorithms can be seen as a
component of a quantum computer they're
a complete software component that
integrates with a complete hardware
component so this is one of the things
that I think is really critical that
when we talk about testing and
benchmarking and characterizing it's
quite different to talk about probing
the behavior of a single gate or a
complete integrated quantum communicate
because sorry quantum computing system
and there's very much overlap between
those problems but they are different
problems and a lot of the literature is
focus to some degree on other things
that don't have to do with quantum
computing and those are good problems
too but they're not my problem and it's
not what I want to talk about today so
mostly what I want to talk about today
is one end of that integration spectrum
I want to talk about what we do to try
and understand the performance of fully
integrated devices so what I mean by
this is
test bed class digital quantum computers
five to fifty cubits maybe as few as two
cubits in some papers generally if you
have one qubit it probably doesn't count
as a quantum computer in my opinion
these are integrated programmable
systems they have qubits they have a
control system that tells the qubits
what gates to run they have
environmental control systems that keep
them cold or vibration isolated or
whatever they're designed to run general
circuits as opposed to special-purpose
devices then there's also the category
of future digital quantum computers here
both the misc era which is what we're
moving into right now and then
extrapolation into the future where it's
hard to predict what we will be able to
do what error rates we will see error
correction will probably be a part of it
but that's a few years into the future
at least there's also analog simulators
which are designed not to execute gates
but to simulate hamiltonians and there's
quantum annealer 'he's like d-wave
produces critical point maybe it's
obvious to everybody on this call but
it's not necessarily obvious in the
broader community there's very few good
reasons to do direct comparisons between
for example analog simulators and
digital quantum computers they're both
quantum but that's almost all they have
in common or between quantum annealer x'
and either misc digital devices or
future digital devices again they're
both called quantum computers they both
use quantum mechanics but their
operation and their level of maturity is
so different that you might as well
compare a quantum annealer to a
neuromorphic computer and if we're in
that game it's reasonable to compare
these to each other but you should also
compare them with laptops and
supercomputers neuromorphic devices etc
etc right there are many different
computing platforms each of the
different quantum platforms really kind
of needs to be benchmarked differently
again this is you're probably all
rolling your eyes at me and saying this
is obvious in which case what I would
say to you is I have a lot of
conversations with people who are
relatively new to the field and very
excited about it to whom this is not
obvious so we test and benchmark and
characterize typically at three
different scales I already talked about
this elementary operations composite
components in the middle and integrated
quantum processors and for each one of
these the question is how well does it
work does it work what does it do how
can I understand and predict its
behavior it's probably a good point to
pause again any questions okay in that
case there's a rule that in these talks
you have to have a three by three grid
with checkmarks in it there's a my
screen just started flashing I'm not
entirely sure why but I assume there's a
well I would relegate a comment from one
of the from Dominique who's in the
attendance saying that he doesn't have a
question but he does laugh at your jokes
so you should continue and make sure to
keep oh good that is the absolute best
sort of feedback I'm tempted to make a
you know laughs machine that sits here
on my desk and you know people can push
the button and make it laugh so back to
my 3x3 grid since I'm contractually
obligated to have one of these what I
want to talk about briefly is which of
these methods would you use for which
component so as I said before we've got
sort of three distinct levels of course
they overlap somewhat but three levels
that we test at there's elementary
operations like single gates composite
components like cycles or subroutines
and fully integrated processors like the
IBM quantum experience and then we have
these three different prototypes of
protocols we can deploy for testing
benchmarking and characterization so
here are some general guidelines
for elementary operations
characterization is a great idea there
are lots of good reasons to understand
as much as possible about what's going
on with an elementary operation
you can also benchmark them but I've
made this yellow because usually we want
more detail and can get more detail
about what an elementary operation is
doing I don't see a lot of purpose in
testing properties of an elementary
operation because what would you want to
know you'd want to know whether they're
perfect or not and I can tell you that
immediately they're not other than that
it's not clear that there are any binary
properties that you really want to know
about elementary operations at the other
end if we look at integrated processors
characterizing twenty or fifty cubits in
detail is probably hopeless and
unnecessary there's just too big on the
other hand benchmarking it sounds like a
great idea we want to find out how well
it works
testing I'm just confused about I'm not
exactly sure what that would mean except
in that sort of crypto paradigm where
I'm testing to see whether it's
executing the program that I asked it to
but even in that case I feel like
ultimately we're probably going to end
up back in the benchmarking regime where
we quantitatively measure these things
but I will confess that that's kind of
outside of my realm of expertise and in
the middle with gate sets or subroutines
or cycles whether we characterize those
things is a really interesting question
that depends on whether it's necessary
what we'd like to do is to characterize
the elementary operations and use those
to predict what the composite components
will do if that prediction fails then we
need to characterize these things in
detail we absolutely want to benchmark
them because that's how we determine
whether they are working and again with
testing I think this makes as much sense
as anything for example to ask does a
particular subroutine work well enough
to be an
corporated in a larger algorithm but I
think usually we want more detail we
want to know how well which we tell us
for instance how many uses of it we
could include in that larger algorithm
before the algorithm would fail so I
want to now talk in a bit more detail
about these three checkmarks
characterizing is usually greater than
benchmarking is greater than testing in
the sense that greater means more
expensive harder but also more
informative so you can usually compute a
benchmark from a characterization you
can usually infer a property test from a
metric but in most cases this is a waste
of time if you want to know the fidelity
of something you probably shouldn't do
tomography and then compute the fidelity
you should try to measure the fidelity
directly there are exceptions as was
pointed out in the last talk diamond
norm is an interesting metric that's
very difficult at this point to measure
directly because it's a kind of a
worst-case thing you almost have to
characterize whatever you're probing in
detail and then calculate the diamond
norm so there are exceptions to this and
that's kind of what makes this game
interesting but in general you kind of
don't want to get more information than
you actually need I put in this slide
because I realized after I'd made my
talk that I kind of skipped something
that I think is kind of important I
talked before about questions like does
this thing work and we talked about what
the things are but we didn't talk about
what it means for something to work this
could be a talk in itself and so I'm not
going to allow myself to just go on for
an hour or even my remaining 22 minutes
talking about all the different
definitions of what it means for a
processor to work or for even a
component or an operation to work or not
work what I really want to do is I want
to tell you it's for you to think about
the fact that that is
non-trivial question it depends on what
we think this thing should be doing and
I'll focus on the particular case of
fully integrated processors and we'll
come back to this in about 10 or 15
minutes but there are many different
things that you could expect a quantum
computer to do it's reasonable to expect
a quantum computer to run quantum
circuits and then you might evaluate it
you might benchmark it based on how well
it runs quantum circuits you would say
can it run this circuit can it run that
circuit on the other hand isn't the
purpose of a quantum computer to solve
problems what if we had a way of solving
computational problems that didn't
require running particular circuits or
any circuits at all
so should we benchmark a processors
ability to run circuits or its ability
to solve problems those are related by
two stages one is algorithms design and
the other is compilation and both of
those are extremely active areas of
research so if we evaluate based on
running circuits we might get one answer
based on current compilation and
algorithm design but if we evaluate
based on how well it can solve problems
we get a different answer and the
relationship between those depends very
much on compiler technology and
algorithm technology that's just one
interesting example of how freaking
important it is to ask what it is that
you think this component should do and
we keep reinventing that alright I want
to move on so I said that I was going to
explore those three check marks and I
want to bring back that diagram the sort
of multi Venn diagram from the very
beginning of what are the topics across
the literature so I want to focus right
now on characterizing elementary
operations I've highlighted these mostly
to spur argument later on as either
relevant ancillary or confusing and I'll
explain what these mean in this case and
just sort of breeze through them in
subsequent iterations if you were
interested in knowing everything about
how to characterize elementary
operations then you should probably read
the literature on process tomography you
should probably read the literature on
hamiltonian tomography you should
probably read the literature on
compressed sensing and low-rank you
should also consider studying related
topics like error metrics or cross talk
or how to describe non Markovian errors
and then there are some topics that have
a very confused relationship with
operation characterization like
randomized benchmarking and machine
learning so here's a sort of brief list
of techniques and topics that are used
for characterizing operations protocols
specifically including ones in Roman
text that I think clearly are optimal
for this and then ones in italics that
are used and useful but not directly
optimized for this task I'll point out
that there is part of the reason for
those italicized ones the the confusing
ones is there's a significant overlap
between characterizing operations and
benchmarking operations so often in
practice tomography gets reduced to a
benchmarking procedure if you ignore the
detailed results and just extract a
fidelity on the other hand randomized
benchmarking often gets promoted defacto
to a characterization procedure by
interpreting the RB error rate as a
predictive model based quantity so these
categories get sort of blurred out I
want to turn now to
marking subroutines and give a very
quick overview of that here the things
that are relevant include state
tomography and it's very it's low ranked
and efficient variants randomized
benchmarking absolutely some forms of
holistic benchmarking studies of
crosstalk and partial tomography there
are some important ancillary fields like
quantum error correction and machine
learning and then I think the
relationship of processed tomography to
benchmarking subroutines is sort of
ambiguous because it is used sometimes
but probably shouldn't be and so here's
a list of the top techniques that have
been used for benchmarking subroutines
of algorithms and whole processors and
finally I want to use most of the rest
of my time to talk about benchmarking
entire processors so this is just a
quick survey like the previous relevant
topics here are pretty focused quantum
error correction and holistic
benchmarking these are the categories of
topics and papers and techniques that
are especially relevant for evaluating
quantitatively the performance of an
entire as-built processor and then
there's some ancillary topics for
instance state tomography randomized
benchmarking tuning crosstalk and
certification and verification and I'll
come back to some of those and talk more
about them in detail and so this is
probably another good point to take a
breath before I embark on the last part
of my talk and see if there's any
questions alright so what I want to do
now is spend about 15 minutes talking
about the ideas that have been proposed
for benchmarking the overall or holistic
performance of quantum processors like
the IBM quantum experience like the
experiment at Innsbruck like I on cue or
Honeywell or Righetti or Google and I'm
not going to try to explain all of these
in detail I want to emphasize my
opinions about which I hope are insights
but maybe they're just
about why these are all different and
why we need more diversity and this is
in part a reaction to something that
I've seen in the community recently not
probably the community that I'm talking
to but the community of business folks
and engineers who are flooding into
quantum computing that we all need to
just standardize on the right technique
we don't we need anarchy we need lots of
benchmarks in the short run we need a
sort of Cambrian explosion so that we
can benchmark the benchmarks if you will
figure out what they're doing which ones
are good via evolution basically all
right so the benchmarks that have been
used and that I'm going to talk about
here are state tomography randomized
benchmarking Google's random circuit
sampling and cross-entropy benchmarking
approach quantum volume algorithms and
volumetric benchmarks and I've chosen
these based on ones that I thought were
interesting to talk about so I do
apologize if I left out deserving
candidates I'm sure that I did and I
also apologize if I put in some
undeserving candidates so let me move
ahead um I was actually really surprised
when I did this monster literature
search to see how often state tomography
is being used as a benchmark for all up
quantum computer performance even today
and in science and nature papers it is I
was shocked by this um it's the most
common benchmark the idea here is that
you demonstrate a processors capability
by programming it to produce a
particular quantum state one that's
considered to be interesting and so this
figure is from Hartman Hefner's nature
paper from back in 2005 where a 1/8 ion
qubit entangled state was produced and
then exhaustively an exhausting way
tamo graft and it
one of those awesome experiments that
made everyone around go that is amazing
that you've done that we never ever want
anyone to do that again I think John way
Pan's group did the same thing with like
14 qubits last year which blew my mind
so this does work it it does prove that
you can do something but it's kind of a
weak demo even in theory all it does is
it demonstrates one particular circuit
in one particular state that you can
prepare which it does I think
demonstrate that but do we really want
to prepare W States is that what we
aspire to in quantum computing I think
we aspire to run interesting circuits
and what I would like to know about a
quantum computer is does it appear have
you proven that you can run lots of
interesting circuits not just the one
that that you picked but the one that
I'm gonna pick later on and state
demography doesn't really demonstrate
that except as a kind of a weak proxy it
just shows that you were able to do this
one thing now the big advantage is that
reconstructing that entire density
matrix should provide fantastic
debugging information it might be hard
to get at but you've got the quantum
state right except usually because
there's errors in the whole process the
state's not perfect the tomography is
not perfect and so the final line of the
paper tends to be something like
fidelity equals 0.7 3 plus or minus 0.04
at which point the question is if that
was your final conclusion why did you do
state tomography in the first place so a
lot of the examples of state tomography
seem to be kind of a waste of time ok
let's talk about randomized benchmarking
randomized benchmarking in its original
and standard form involves running many
random sequences of Clifford operations
so the top figure here demonstrates this
we start with all of the qubit
prepared in the zero state and then we
do some randomly selected Clifford
operation and another randomly selected
Clifford operation and another one and
at the end we do a final inversion
Clifford that cancels out all the ones
that came before it creates an entire
circuit that's supposed to perform the
identity and then we measure to see
where that there actually did the
problem with doing this on more than
about three or four qubits is that as
you can see from this diagram and qubit
Clifford's have to be compiled into a
lot of elementary gates about N squared
of them depending on things like
connectivity so what happens is these
circuits are so big that even the
shortest Clifford RB circuit for more
than about three or four cubits has zero
probability of succeeding there's a
variant that we introduced called direct
randomized benchmarking that's more
scalable but it still only scales to
about 10 cubits on current platforms but
so random is benchmarking is measuring a
meaningful and well-motivated quantity
and I've showed here some experimental
results from our paper on direct RB
where we took different two three four
and five qubit subsets of a particular
IBM quantum experience processor thank
you IBM and benchmarked them with direct
RB measured this exponential decay curve
and looked at pretty much the quantity
that Joseph was talking about in his
previous talk the effective error rate
per circuit layer cycle and layer mostly
mean the same thing we have obscure
arguments within the specialist
community about which word is better the
effective error rate per circuit layer
in random unstructured Clifford circuits
so this is what you're measuring it's a
good quantity however it's not the end
all and be all of everything because as
Joseph pointed out earlier errors have
structure and so what this is doing is
twirling everything down to one number
and it is in extra
inextricably linked to the particular
ensemble of circuits that you chose to
run and that's always the case with a
benchmark right you have to look at what
circuits are being run and ask how
general is that um in this case we're
running for either variant of our be
random circuits that twirl errors how
those errors combine whether they have a
limited way limited opportunity to add
up coherently or no opportunity to add
up coherently or how the structure of
the errors impacts the circuit outcome
depends on exactly how you compile your
clifford's and clifford's can be
compiled according to different
compilation tables and this can lead to
significant variations in the number
that you get out all of them are valid
but it's a bit tricky to go in and see
what am I actually learning about here
in addition you're only getting from the
standard way of writing the benchmark
the average behavior and if you look at
this experimental data you can see the
black dots showing the success
probability as a function of sequence
length but around each one there's a
violin plot a halo and that shows
individual circuits that got averaged
together they all have the same length
and for this green violin that I hope
everyone can see it stretches from about
20% success probability all the way up
to about 70% success probability so the
mean of that is 40% but there's a huge
variation within those random circuits
so this benchmark is focusing on average
behavior specific start cuts are not
necessarily predicted by that and that's
something that's common to pretty much
all of the major benchmarks they're
being run right now I didn't I have a
quick question what's the significance
of using Clifford circuits is it just
out of convenience or is it like why not
have you know a universal gate set or
when you're running these random
sequences that is a rabbit hole question
you know you ask what's the significance
house
sniffing it is for the question what am
i learning from this is a really
interesting question and I'll try to
come back to that a little bit later um
an easier question that I'm going to
pretend you asked is why do you use
Clifford circuits and the answer if I go
back another slide is that they have
this concise group structure that lets
me go out and back again and perform
identity circuits but without going out
and back along the same path right I can
do a random walk over the group because
I have a large group that explores the
entire hilbert space or at least a large
chunk of it without infinitely long gate
sequences and the problem is that if I
do a random circuit that doesn't have
that restricted Clifford structure and
then I try to come back to get an
identity operation pretty much the only
reliable way to do it is to invert that
circuit and now I'm just going out and
back I really like to go around loops in
the group space I say so somehow for
Clifford circuits you you have efficient
ways of computing different
representations of the same unitary
different circuit representations or
something like that so in the slide that
I'm showing right now
no matter how long that seat this
sequence of blue random Clifford's is
there's always an efficiently computable
single inversion clifford that brings me
back to where I started so I can do
efficient random walks with inversion on
that group whereas the full unitary
group I can't okay got it thanks ok so
the most exciting thing going on of
course is quantum supremacy and it's not
entirely clear what to call this
benchmark Google didn't really treat it
as a benchmark per se so what I've
called it is cross-entropy benchmarking
slash random circuit sampling because
you could do cross-entropy benchmarking
with other circuits as well and you
don't have to do cross entry you can do
other things with random circuit
sampling
the circuits here are pretty similar to
direct RB circuits but they use non
Clifford gates and so we following up on
the last question this explores more of
the Hilbert space Clifford
circuits explore all the stabilizer
states which form a to design and they
kind of span the hilbert space in a
powerful way but you might ask well what
about the non stabilizer States does
this quantum computer have the ability
to explore those as well and that's
essentially what Google was
demonstrating that they could explore
states that were relatively arbitrary I
mean in the sense that they could be
produced by short depth circuits but as
random as possible much more random than
stabilizer States because they didn't
use clifford gates these circuits also
have a particular alternating layer
structure to them and like very good
random clifford circuits they scramble
local errors and this is really
important because scrambling turns out
to be what you need you don't actually
need twirling which is what Joseph
demonstrated with the Polli twirling to
get rid of coherent errors scrambling is
enough to get most of the same power as
Clifford twirling for reducing errors to
a very simple generic form now the the
famous cross result of not using
clifford circuits is that these circuits
are very hard to simulate and I mean
assume that everybody was paying
attention during the big exciting result
last year when Google claimed and
probably demonstrated quantum supremacy
and that's precisely because when you
run one of these crosses these random
circuits with non Clifford gates on
fifty-three qubits for 50 cycles
I guess they only may have gone to 20
cycles you can't simulate it feasibly on
a classical computer of course there's
been some you know arguing about that
but the basic principle holds for
benchmarking this is a problem because
you want to be able to simulate it so
the
you can see whether you got the right
answer and so Google had to really jump
through some complicated hoops to argue
that they had gotten the right answer
when it couldn't be checked efficiently
I'm running out of time so I'm gonna
come back to random circuit sampling in
a minute I want to compare it really
with quantum volume this is also
something that most of you have probably
heard of IBM proposed quantum volume as
the first really intentional holistic
benchmark it gives you one number and
it's supposed to describe the dimension
of the Hilbert space that can be
accessed uniformly in practice it's
usually the number of qubits whose
hilbert space you can access uniformly
so there's a volume versus log to a
volume that can be awfully confusing if
at this point if somebody says they have
a quantum volume of 64 it means they
have a quantum volume of 6 cubits I
don't think anybody has gotten into 64
qubits which would be volume of 2 to the
64 yet there's a bit of marketing that
might be going on there but what's more
interesting is quantum volume specifies
a particular test suite a set of
circuits to run there are another class
of minimally structured random circuits
the width and the depth vary together so
you run circuits that are width D and
also depth D they involve D qubits and D
layers of random operations but unlike
randomized benchmarking or well sorry
unlike Google's benchmark and mostly
unlike randomized benchmarking these are
specified by logical operations not
physical gates so the operations that
are specified in the quantum volume
circuit are for instance random
permutations that's a kind of a
high-level programming language where
they are random to qubit su4 operations
that again is a high-level programming
language it's completely left up to the
architect and the compiler how to
actually implement these and so for one
thing the physical depth of a quantum
volume circuit the
number of actual clock cycles is
typically much greater than D so here's
really the question that I want to get
to is there any sense in which these are
measuring the same thing they really
aren't they have a lot of similarities
and you could easily be forgiven by
saying oh they're basically the same
thing they both produce random states
they both use non clifford gates and
there's success metrics while they
appear to be different are actually very
close to the same thing one is heavy
output probability one is linear cross
entropy there's very little difference
in practice the big difference is that
quantum volume is specifying a unitary
not a circuit quantum volumes says here
is a unitary I am going to tell you that
unitary by specifying being it as a
circuit that's an efficient way of
specifying a unitary but you're allowed
to compile it however the heck you want
random circuit sampling as implemented
by Google has specific circuits and in
each case the width and the depth are
four random circuit sampling the
physical width and the physical depth of
that circuit and then by running the
experiment you find out how well you ran
it for quantum volume you're told a
logical width and a logical depth and
you're allowed to compile those however
the heck you want so really these are
measuring different things one of them
is asking how well can you run certain
unit Ares the other is asking how well
can you run certain circuits depending
on compiler and architecture those may
have wildly differing relationships I
want to steal a little bit of time just
to say in the long run we probably want
to run quantum algorithms as a benchmark
it's also probably premature at this
point because algorithms are evolving
too fast to make a stable benchmark and
the test beds that we have can't really
run any meaningful algorithms yet we
really do want to see how these test bit
processors run algorithmic like circuits
but we just can't do meaningfully big
one
yet and then I want to give a minute to
talk about something that my group
introduced and wrote about last year
called volumetric benchmarks and our
motivation was that a lot of people want
to know how capable is a quantum
processor what circuits can it actually
run successfully because people want to
run small algorithm circuits they want
to demonstrate certain things if your
circuit is too big to be run on the
computer there's no sense in running it
and whether a computer can actually run
a circuit is largely determined by the
width the number of qubits the depth the
number of cycles or layers and then what
kind of circuit is it what's the
structure so quantum volume measures
your ability to run square circuits if
you were to plot this on a width versus
depth plot you test all of the red
circuits until you reached a failure and
then you would know that everything in
this box could be run we thought square
circuits are cool but rectangular
circuits are better so we introduced
this idea of volumetric benchmarks as a
kind of a tupperware if quantum volume
is a tasty soup we thought there are
many different kinds of soup you could
have pea soup or squash soup or or even
lentil soup or stew for that matter or
lasagna but they all go in Tupperware
and so we basically created a sort of a
framework that's like a Tupperware that
you can stuff whatever class of circuits
you find most interesting into if you
like random circuits you can stuff them
into volumetric benchmarks if you like
periodic circuits or if you like
algorithm circuits you can stuff them
into volumetric benchmarks and there's a
paper on the archive it'd be great if
you looked it up and told us what you
thought and I'll tease with some actual
data for a forthcoming paper where we
used this approach to actually probe the
capability of a bunch of different test
beds that were available online and here
I've shown various processors available
for on from IBM we're asking a simple
question at a given depth
and at a given width we run a bunch of
circuits did they all succeed if so
that's where it gets colored dream if
they all failed
it gets colored white and if some of
them ran but some of them failed we
color it Orange if the error model was
simple the orange region wouldn't exist
you'd go straight from green to white
the circuit structure wouldn't matter
as you can see sir constructor does
matter a lot which if you were here for
Joe's talk last time you probably won't
be surprised by these things are
complicated so my conclusion is we're
developing new ideas benchmarking and
characterization are different and we
need more creative benchmarks we also
need to know what they measure what are
we actually measuring because quantum
computers are complicated beasts so
there's a survey of benchmarking thanks
Robin so we technically don't have time
but in practice we do have time for
questions so feel free to speak up or
try to question into the pattern with
the Q&A maybe I'll ask just one question
while other people think about it so in
this how do you think about the you kind
of address this on your mandatory 2 by 3
square well how do you think about the
sort of scaling issue so these
benchmarking everything that you that
you said specially at the end like
running these circuits and algorithm
circuits or random circuits clipping
circuits are a bit randomized skippered
benchmarking is a bit different because
you know exactly what to expect
I mean you can simulate everything
classically so it's not a problem but so
these kinds of approaches they're doing
well for 20 cubits or something because
you can you know what you're looking for
but beyond that what what's gonna happen
how do you think that are we going to go
back to gate by gate or you know
subsystem in a benchmarks or so I think
that you know as
conclusion says we need characterization
and benchmarking and we need to be
benchmarking at every level of
integration from the biggest down to the
smallest gates but we will let me focus
on what I talked about here which is
protocols for holistic benchmarking um
we need efficiently verifiable circuits
I think that going forward it's clear
har random circuits are dead so what
those will look like my group is
pursuing particular ideas I'm sure that
a bunch of other groups are pursuing
pursuing particular ideas I'm really
looking forward to the creative ideas
that I can't even foresee at this point
we need efficiently verifiable circuits
whether those are you know clifford's
with some variations or planted
solutions or there's so much room for
creativity but we are going to need
efficiently verifiable circuits and you
don't worry that you know somehow
there'd be a kind of a strange
computational phase transition where you
know the machine would work for any
efficiently verifiable circuit but like
clifford's but if you step out of there
something so edgy that is a fantastic
rabbit hole question and you know let me
officially say anybody who who wants to
cheerfully have that argument like that
would be a great outcome of this
workshop because no I don't worry about
that in the slightest I am utterly
confident that there is no phase
transition at you know like the
performance has nothing to do with the
difficulty of simulating um but I
acknowledge that it's a fantastic
question and I've heard you know I would
love to have some knock-down drag-out
debates with folks coming from you know
the community where that makes more
sense because I totally don't think
it'll be that way but let's all hash
this out and come to some sort of
agreement
there's one question in the Q&A Debbie
okay Little Debbie let me ask the
question for you she's asking if how
about using quantum error correcting
codes instead of algorithms in order to
do benchmarking absolutely so those are
I didn't talk about that here because as
you saw I ran out of time anyway I
focused on benchmarking NIST type
computers and for that you assume that
they're gonna be used to run algorithm
circuits and you run test circuits that
look sort of like algorithm circuits qec
is incredibly important and the circuits
that you will run for qec are really
really really different they are a very
important category of their own it's
like a different kingdom of nature right
you've got plants and archaeans or
something and they are their own thing
we should absolutely run benchmarks for
qec but it's a totally separate purpose
and there's there's surprisingly little
overlap between the holistic
benchmarking approaches for error
correction and furnace at the
characterization level I think they're
pretty similar but they diverge once you
get to evaluating benchmarking thank you
are there any more questions
just
thanks Rob and I you made me chuckle a
few times and I appreciate that thank
you that's that's my goal in life okay
so on that note let's end the talk I
thank Robin again for the great
expository talk well thanks a lot so we
have a bit of a break until 3:30 and
then we'll resume with the laughs last
talk I guess maybe Robin is hanging
around for a few minutes in case anyone
comes up with a question